PROFESSOR: All
right, so lecture 11
was about generic
rigidity of linkages.
So we've got bars and vertices
connected together in a graph.
And generically, the
graph is all that matters.
And we characterize in two
ways, Henneberg construction
and Laman when graphs
are generically rigid.
And in particular, there
was this pebble algorithm
that was supposed to tell
you in polynomial time
whether you're a graph
was Laman or not.
And everyone pretty much asked
about this, about the details,
including myself when
I watched it like, huh,
that seems a little sketchy.
So I thought I'd spend
most of today going
through how that
algorithm works exactly
and also why it's correct, which
is definitely not obviously.
It vaguely feels correct, but
we'll see why it actually is.
Remember Laman's Theorem,
Laman characterization
is that your graph is
generically rigid if and only
if every subgraph-- let's
say every k vertices induces
at most to 2k minus 3 edges.
That's part one.
And you also need
that the number
of edges overall in
the graph is 2n minus 3
where n is the total
number vertices.
So this was just the
degree of freedom count.
You have 2n degrees of freedom
for every vertex minus 3
for the rigid motions, two
translations, one rotation.
So that's the number of
edges you should have total.
Sorry.
This is for minimally
generically rigid.
And then to make it
balance, you want
to guarantee that every
k vertices doesn't
have too many edges.
Because if it has
too many edges,
there'd be too few
somewhere else.
This part would be
overbrace, some other part
would be underbrace,
and you'd be flexible.
That's the intuition.
And so the tricky
part comes down
to how do you check whether
every k vertices induces
2k minus 3 edges because they're
exponentially many choices.
There's 2 to the n different
choices of subsets or vertices.
For each of them,
you'd have to check.
That's no good.
So the algorithm
wants to check this.
And I'm going to
call this property
the 2k minus 3 property.
And we're going to warm up
with a simpler problem, which
is to check to the 2k
property without the minus 3.
So 2k property is
just every k vertices
induce at most 2k edges.
So this'll be a little
easier to think about,
more or less the same, a
lot easier to argue about.
And then we'll see how
to modify the algorithm
to check the 2k
minus 3 property.
Was the property clear and
in particular inducing?
Inducing means that you
have some set of vertices,
and there's the rest of the
vertices, n minus k of them.
You only look at edges where
both endpoints are in the set,
both of them are
among the k vertices.
So you ignore vertices that have
one end in k and the other end
outside.
And you ignore, obviously, edges
that have both ends outside.
Just count these guys.
So how do we do this?
Give you the algorithm.
Actually, let me first give
you the idea of the algorithm
before we go to the
actual algorithm.
And this is review,
but pretty soon we'll
get to stuff that wasn't
covered in lecture.
So the idea is every vertex
has two pebbles inside of it.
I'll draw as two red dots.
And they can cover
incident edges.
So they can't move very far.
They have to stay
basically on the inside
or on the boundary
of the vertex.
That's how I'm going to draw it.
Each pebble can cover
one incident edge.
So for example,
there's a little graph.
I could take--
let's maybe I leave
one of the pebbles
in the middle.
I can move one of the pebbles
to cover one of the edges.
So I'll put it this
intersection to denote
it's covering this edge, but it
still belongs to this vertex.
Pebbles cannot change vertices.
They have to stay local.
These two pebbles could
just stay where they are.
Here, we could put
one pebble here,
another pebble there, one
pebble here, one pebble here.
This is what I call
a pebble cover cause
every edge is covered
by some pebble.
That's the goal in a pebble
cover is to cover every edge.
You need to cover it once.
And the pebbles can either cover
an edge or they can be free.
Free if they're just
hanging out in the inside
here not being
used for anything.
So our goal is to
find pebble covers.
But the first claim, why do
I care about pebble covers,
I claimed that
having a pebble cover
is equivalent to
the 2k property.
So that's what I want to show.
So let's start with that.
This is why
everything is working.
A graph has a 2k property if and
only if it has a pebble cover.
So that's why we care about
these pebble coverings.
And this is actually
pretty easy to prove
and gives a lot of intuition
for why everything works here.
So let's start with
the left direction.
So suppose I have
a pebble cover.
Suppose somehow I've
achieved this property,
covering all the edges, using
only two pebbles per vertex.
I claim that we then
satisfy the 2k property.
2k property says you
take any key vertices,
you induce at most
two key edges.
So let's consider k vertices.
Someone chooses k vertices.
doesn't matter which.
It should hold for all
of them, for all choices.
So we've got a k vertices here.
n minus k vertices remaining.
We claim that the number
of edges induced by those k
vertices is at most 2k.
So look at one of these
edges that's wholly inside,
that's induced by
these k vertices.
I claim, well, that edge
must be covered by a pebble.
Which pebble?
Well, either this one or
one on the other side.
But the point is it
is covered by a pebble
among these vertices.
My concern is, well, maybe you
worry about an edge like this.
Or, maybe you worry
about a pebble
here that's covering this
edge, but that edge is not
one of the induced edges.
So these vertices are relevant.
It's just the pebbles inside,
just among these 2k pebbles.
So in here, there
are 2k pebbles.
They must fully cover
the induced subgraph.
They must cover all
the edges in here.
That means they're
at most 2k edges
because there's one
pebble per edge at least.
And so there's 2k
pebbles in here.
This means they're at
must 2k induced edges.
Clear?
That's the obvious direction.
This doesn't really exploit
very much about pebbles.
The other direction is a
little more interesting.
Why should these
pebble covers exist?
Because they seem
pretty constrained.
Pebbles can't move very far.
It's not really clearly
the same, but it is.
So if we have the 2k property--
So now we know that every
subgraph of k vertices
induces at most 2k edges.
Now, we want to prove that
a pebble cover exists.
I'm going to wait.
It will become
obvious momentarily.
This is fun.
Sometimes, it's easier
to prove a theorem
than it is to come
up with an algorithm.
But in this case, it's easier
to come up with an algorithm
than it is to prove a theorem.
And you can use the algorithm
itself to prove the theorem,
so I'm going to prove
this in a moment.
Stay tuned.
Meanwhile, we have an algorithm.
This algorithm is
an example of what
we call an incremental style
algorithm where you imagine
starting with the
empty graph and then
you put in all the edges
that belong one at a time.
So add edges one at a time
starting from nothing.
One detail is we're going to
imagine as edges get added,
we want to direct them.
We're going to direct edges
from the pebble that covers them
to the other side.
So if we have an edge and
we have a pebble over here,
than I'm going to imagine
the edge as being directed
from the pebble
to the other side.
That's just for convenience
for expressing the algorithm
in a moment.
So now this is for
the 2k property.
We'll get to an algorithm
for 2k minus 3 a little bit.
So now we have a 4 loop over
the edge is we're going to add.
And when I immediately add an
edge, it will not be covered,
so it's not directed,
just some edge v-w.
I would like to
put a pebble here,
but it could be
both pebbles at w
are occupied for
some other edges.
It could be the
pebbles for v are also
occupied for some other edges.
That would be annoying.
I want to somehow reassign
a pebble to cover this edge,
so what I'm going to
do inside this 4 loop
is search for available pebbles.
And in this case, what
turns out to be right
is a directed path in
this directed graph
from either v or w
to a free pebble.
Either I find one or I don't.
If I find one, let's
say from v, there's
some edge and then some other
edge and some other edge.
And eventually, I
find a free pebble.
Remember a free pebble is one
that's floating on the inside,
not being used for anything.
So what does my
picture look like?
Remember edges are
directed from the pebbles.
That means there was a pebble
at v being used for that edge.
There was a pebble
at this vertex
being used for that edge.
There was a pebble
at this vertex
being used for that edge.
In this case, what do I do?
AUDIENCE: Reverse.
PROFESSOR: Reverse them, yeah.
Just reverse all the edges.
So I have this edge, v-w, here.
I want to put a
pebble here, so I'm
going to reassign this guy
to be over there, this guy
to be over there, and so on.
So I end up with--
that's in the way.
Put w over here.
The new picture
is I have v and w.
And I'm going to have
left 4 directed edges.
So now this pebble got
assigned to be here.
I can't draw left apparently.
The other left.
This pebble assigned there.
This pebble, the free
pebble, gets used up.
And now we've got a
free pebble over here.
And now we can assign it
to be on the edge v-w.
So if I can find such a
path from v or from w,
I'm happy because
then I can reassign.
If I find such a path, I just
shift the pebbles like that,
and I'm done.
But what if I can't?
This is the critical
issue, and it is also
core to this part
of the proof that we
haven't discover--
haven't yet done.
Why would we hope
for pebble covers
to exist in the first place?
We don't know.
I claim if this
algorithm fails to find
a path in this situation,
then you can immediately
say you do not satisfy
the 2k property.
I'd like to say there's
no pebble cover,
but that's a little harder.
I'm going to say you do not
satisfy the 2k property.
And we actually know
already, from this part,
pebble cover
implies 2k property.
The contrapositive, which
we've already proved,
is if you do not
satisfy the 2k property,
you do not have a pebble cover.
So that will actually guarantee
correctness of the algorithm.
If I can prove this part,
that it violates 2k property,
then I'll know there was no
pebble cover, and I'm done.
So why is this true.
I claim if you look at
all the nodes reachable
by directed paths
from v and w, then
that is a set of nodes that
induce more than 2k edges.
So let's say their k
nodes you can reach.
I claim there will be more
than 2k edges among them.
Why?
It's fun to have proof in
the middle of an algorithm.
So here we've got to
v and w, and these
are the k nodes that are
reachable from v and w, which
means all of the other edges
are pointing into this set.
And then, over here,
we have everybody else.
I mean it might be everyone.
But potentially, there's
some vertices over here.
All the edges are directed
from right to left,
otherwise we could
reach more stuff.
So what's the situation?
v-w is uncovered.
There's no pebbles
that cover it.
Every other edge is
covered because there's
only one uncovered
edge at any moment.
These edges are all
covered from this end.
That's what these
directions mean, which
means all the
pebbles in here are
used to cover induced edges.
So all the pebbles in here
are covering induced edges,
and yet, there's one induced
edge that is not covered.
Now they're exactly 2k pebbles.
They're all being used.
I'm assuming here you never
have two pebbles covering
the same edge, so that
means-- so there's 2k pebbles.
They're all used to cover
induced edges, which
implies you have
exactly 2k plus 1 edges.
Plus 1 is v-w.
That means that means the
graph that we've created so far
violates the 2k property.
Now, we haven't added
all the edges yet,
but if we add more
edge, it's going
to get even worse potentially.
If we have 2k plus 1 edges
now, in the actual graph,
we'll have at least
2k plus 1 edges.
So if this search
fails, you know
that you violate the
2k property, which
means you know that
there's no pebble cover.
So that proves correctness
of the algorithm.
Now we can come
back to this claim.
This follows, by correctness
of the algorithm, why.
We want to prove if we
have the 2k property,
then you have a pebble copper.
Well, if I have the 2k property,
this algorithm will work.
This case can never
happen because it can only
happen when you violate
the 2k property.
So if you have the 2k
property, this algorithm,
you can keep running it.
You will always find a path.
You'll be able to
shift the pebbles
and always cover things, and
so you get a pebble cover
from the algorithm.
The end.
That's how you argue that
if you have the 2k property,
you get a pebble cover.
And it's nifty.
Without this
algorithm, this would
be quite tricky to specify.
But the algorithm tells
you where the violation
would be, tells you where you
would violate the 2k property.
And that lets you prove
the claim ultimately.
Any questions about that.
This, I think, is the
heart of pebble algorithms
and why they work.
It's the cleanest part.
It gets a little bit messier
to do the 2k minus 3 thing,
so we'll move to that next.
Maybe before we go there, we
can talk about the running time
of the algorithm for
those so inclined.
So the heart of the
algorithm is this step,
search for directed path
for v or w to a free pebble.
This is essentially some of
the nodes have free pebbles.
Those are like good nodes.
But basically, we've
got a directed graph.
We want to find all the nodes
that are reachable from v,
see if there's any good
nodes that have free pebbles,
search from all
the nodes from w.
This you could do with a depth
first search or a breadth
first search or your
favorite search algorithm.
Takes linear time.
Order the number of
vertices plus the number
of edges in the graph.
We do this search v times.
Why v times?
So we add edges one at a time.
We're hoping that we
have the 2k property.
The 2k property implies
that, in particular,
there at most 2v edges.
So in general, we
do this e times.
We keep adding edges.
We would add e edges
to the graph hopefully.
In general, e can be much
larger than v in a graph. e
could v squared, the worst case.
But this algorithm
will fail by the time
you add 2k plus 1 edges
because then you definitely
don't satisfy the 2k property
over the entire graph,
so particularly you
won't satisfy it
on some subset of vertices.
So you will only have to
run this loop v times,
not e times-- or 2v times.
So this is a little bit
smaller, and so this product
is v squared plus ve.
Normally, we write ve, but
this is slightly more precise,
which is the same
as Bellman Ford
algorithm if you've
taken algorithms.
I'll just mention that there is
an algorithm slightly fancier
that just requires this term.
This is possible.
You don't need this ve part.
but it's beside the point
to our goal, which is just
to understand when
things are rigid,
when they're not in an
efficient amount of time.
So this is polynomial
in any case.
This also the best known
algorithm, v squared.
Open problem is whether
you could do better.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there more than 2v
edges instead of, [INAUDIBLE]
that [INAUDIBLE] problem.
PROFESSOR: Yes, there
are more than to v edges.
Oh, right!
So there's done.
Great.
You can just check in the
beginning, are there more
than to v edges.
If so, you do not satisfy the 2k
property, and so you can stop.
So that takes constant time to
check those cases, otherwise e
is small.
And then you only
take the square time.
Thanks.
That's key.
So that was the 2k property.
Let's do 2k minus 3.
For the 2k minus
3 algorithm, it's
going to be pretty much
the same as this algorithm.
So in particular, every
vertex is to attach pebbles.
Each pebble can cover
when it's in an edge,
otherwise it's free.
Our goal is to cover every edge.
But it's slightly differently.
We have to deal with
this minus 3 business.
And for that we need
another claim, which
is that a graph has a
2k minus 3 property if
and only if g plus three
copies of an edge e
has the 2k property for
every edge, e and g.
Should probably say g has.
So I want to know whether
my-- ultimately, I
care whether my graph has
a 2k minus 3 property.
This is most of the
Laman condition.
It's the hard part to check.
And 2k property is what
I know how to check.
So I claim all you need
to do to check it--
this would actually
be an algorithm.
For every edge, turn
that single edge
into four copies of the
edge, add three more,
check whether it
has the 2k property,
remove those extra three
copies, take the next edge,
add three copies,
check the 2k property.
So with another
factor of e, which
has to be order v, if you're
willing to spend v cubed time,
you can just run this
algorithm for each edge,
quadruple it, see whether it
still has the 2k property.
So that's the connection
between these 2 things.
Let me prove this claim.
And then I'll tell
you a better algorithm
that only takes v squared time.
Which one's easier?
In both cases, I want
to take k vertices.
And then I'll do in
this direction first.
So how do we prove this?
First, this is
actually really easy.
Suppose g has a 2k
minus 3 property.
So if I have k
vertices here, I know
that the number of edges in
here is at most 2k minus 3.
So here's k vertices.
Looking at the number
of induced edges,
it's going to be
at most 2k minus 3.
What I'm claiming is then
if I quadruple an edge,
if I add three new edges, I have
at most 2k edges afterwards.
I think that's pretty clear.
2k minus 3 would be 4 at most.
If I add three copies of any
edge, could be in this set
or outside the set
would be even better,
the number of edges inside
the set will be at most 2k.
So this is in g.
This implies there's at
most 2k and g plus thrice e.
This is non-standard
notation by the way.
It just means add three
copies of that edge.
So we would normally
draw that like this,
four copies of the edge.
So that was half of the
claim, pretty trivial.
The other half is
almost as trivial.
So on the other
direction, we assume
that g plus 3e has this
property for every edge.
And now we need to prove
that g has a 2k minus 3
property for every
set of k vertices.
So we're looking at
that set of k vertices.
We want to argue
that in g, there's
at most 2k minus 3 edges.
What we know is that in here,
in g plus 3 e for any e--
so it's a little awkward--
but let me start by drawing g.
We want to claim that the
number of edges in here
is at most 2k minus 3, so
I'll put a question mark.
So there are 2
possibilities here.
It could be either this
graph is completely empty.
If there are no edges in
here, then surely there
are at most 2k minus
3 of them, assuming k
is bigger than 1, which
I haven't mentioned.
But throughout here, I need
the k is bigger than 1.
You can never have negative
1 edges on subgraphs,
so the 2k in the 2k
minus 3 property only
hold for at least 2 vertices.
K is at least 2.
So if there are no
edges, find I'm done.
If there are edges in here,
then I can do this trick.
So there's some edge.
Pick your favorite edge.
Call it e in this subset.
Produce out of it
g plus 3e, which
just looks like the
same thing, but now it's
got four copies of that edge.
This we know has at
most 2k edges in here.
The original graph
is exactly the same
except it lacks those
three edges, therefore,
there's at most 2k
minus 3 of them.
So it's really the same
proof in both directions.
Here, you have to
use your freedom
in choosing e to
choose an edge that
is induced in this subgraph.
You can't choose some
other edge out here.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So this seems
kind of cheap because we're
using the graph as a
linkage in the end,
so adding these extra edges,
they all collapse into one.
PROFESSOR: Ah, interesting.
Right.
So why this feels
like cheating because,
from a linkage
perspective, these 2 guys
have exactly the
same constraints.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I agree.
It's weird.
At this point, this is a device.
You could think of
it as adding edges.
Another way to think
of it is this edge
has to be covered
by four pebbles.
That's probably a
little more intuitive.
So having to cover an
edge by four pebbles,
essentially, is
pinning the edge.
Because on the one hand, you
have a single pebble just
to say this is an edge.
And then you have
three more pebbles
to eat up the translations
and rotations.
That's intuitively
what's going on.
I agree this looks weird.
And at this point, we're just
playing the graph theory game
and ignoring the linkages.
That's the short
answer why this is OK.
But ultimately,
intuitively, what's going on
is that these three
edges are just
representing the translations
and rotations being eaten.
And they have to be
somehow eatable universally
at every edge.
That's what this is saying.
I don't have a great
intuition for that,
but it is-- pretty
sure you do need
to say for every edge,
not just some edge.
So at this point, you have
a polynomial time algorithm,
so I'm done.
But let me briefly mention
how you could make it faster
by modifying this algorithm to
do the 2k minus 3 situation.
Dare I-- I won't literally
modify the algorithm.
I'll write a new version.
But I'm going to use that
as a subroutine basically.
And so algorithm
2k minus 3 version.
So it's going to
be the same style.
We're going to add
edges one at a time.
We'll direct the edges in the
same way for each added edge
v-w.
I'll just write for
each added edge v-w.
Before I just tried to add the
edge and cover it with pebble.
Now, I want to cover
it with four pebbles.
I want to basically add
the edge four times.
I'm going to write as
above to mean this step.
So every time I add
the edge, I search
for a directed path from
v or w for free pebble.
When I find it, I
do the pebble shift.
I do that four times.
Then basically, I have
four pebbles on the edge,
or you could think of them as
being four copies of the edge,
each has one pebble.
Either I succeed and I get all
four, or I don't get all four.
On success, this is just
a temporary measure.
At that point, I'm going to
delete three of the copies.
Put it back to a
regular single edge.
This frees three
pebbles for future use.
So I don't want every
edge to be quadrupled.
I don't want them all to
be quadrupled at once.
I want to try
quadrupling one edge,
then try quadrupling
the next edge,
try quadrupling the next edge.
But when I'm
quadrupling an edge,
all the other edges
exist as single edges.
So I delete the three copies.
And then this four loop
continues and tries
the next edge.
On failure-- here I'm
going to say something
more interesting-- Normally,
on failure I'd say,
well, you don't satisfy
the 2k minus 3 property.
Game over.
But you can be a little
more sophisticated.
Just say delete all
the copies of e.
I guess there's four of them.
Whatever pebbles you can
acquire, you give them up.
Delete the edge and
call the edge redundant.
Basically, in this
case, you could
argue that edge was superfluous
for rigidity purposes.
You didn't need it.
So the algorithm
doesn't just fail.
It says this was a useless edge.
And it'll tell you
which edges are useful,
which ones are non-redundant
from a rigidity standpoint.
And then when you're done,
you will be rigid if and only
if the number of non-redundant
edges that remain
equals 2n minus 3.
So that's the last part
of the Laman check.
So this is giving you a
little bit more information
than just do I satisfy
the 2k minus 3 property.
To get that, you just check
whether you ever failed.
But in this case,
you can actually
see, ah, these are
the useless edges.
They're those overbracing edges.
Everything else is useful.
And if I end up having enough
useful edges to n minus 3
of them, then I know I'm rigid.
Otherwise, I'm going
to be flexible.
So this gives you all
the information you want.
With a little bit
more effort, you
could even figure out if I'm
flexible, which parts are rigid
and which parts can move
relative to each other.
This, of course,
generically rigid.
Finally, let me show you
this thing in action.
So look over there.
This is an implementation
by Audrey Lee-Saint John.
And so here's a simple graph.
You can probably see this
top part is flexible.
It's quadrilateral.
Bottom part is overbraced.
This is in 2 dimensions, right?
So just triangles
would be enough,
but I've added an
extra edge here.
And this is going to check
the Laman condition one
step at a time.
So we start with 2
pebbles everywhere.
We start by adding
that top edge.
Right now, there are four
pebbles on that edge,
so it's great.
I can just add the edge.
Let's say I added it four times.
There are four pebbles there.
But then in the end,
I just need one.
So let's skip that step.
And now I've got the one
pebble from b, and we're happy.
So that is its own
rigid component.
Next, let's add this edge ef.
So this also has four
pebbles on it, so we're done.
Next, we have cd.
That also has-- you
could change the order
if you think this
one's a little trivial.
Now is when the action happens.
Let's add this edge bc.
So currently, it is only
covered by three pebbles.
But we need a fourth.
So we're going to take one
of these free pebbles on a
and move it along b.
We found that by starting
from b and searching out
and finding a free pebble.
So we just flip that edge.
Now we've got a
free pebble on b.
Now we've got four pebbles on
bc, and we can add the edge.
But we only actually
take one of them.
So I'm skipping the part
where we add the four copies
and immediately remove three
of them because that's silly.
Cool.
So that's its own rigid
component it turns out.
Each of these things
is independently--
the colors represent
rigid components.
And right now nothing
is tied together.
Everything's flexible.
Flexible at b.
Flexible at c.
Let's add this diagonal df.
So right now, it
only has one pebble,
which means we
need four pebbles.
So we're actually going
to have to get one at f,
and we're going
to have to get one
at d because there can
only be two at each.
So first, we'll do I
guess a search from d,
and we immediately
find a pebble.
We move it down there.
Great.
Then, we search from f.
We find a pebble there.
We move it.
Boom!
We've got our edge,
added all four pebbles.
Eventually we're going
to run out of pebbles,
but right now, we
are very flexible.
Let's add this other diagonal.
This should also be possible.
Right now, there's one
pebble at e, one pebble at c.
We've got to find
two more pebbles.
So first, we'll
follow this edge.
Find a free pebble at f.
That was easy.
Next, we'll look at from c.
There's only one way
we can go from c.
We can't follow the back edge.
Got to go forward.
Got a pebble at d.
Flip it around.
Now, we've got four pebbles on
c and e, so we can add the edge.
Now, let's add ef.
Right now, we've only got
one pebble, yet we need four.
So let's start by
searching from a.
Oh, we found a
pebble immediately.
In general, we would have
to follow many edges.
So there's a from f.
There are two ways we could go.
Either one of them would
have given us a pebble.
Let's flip the yellow edge.
Boom!
We've got f, one pebble,
but we need another one.
Now, we cannot get another
pebble from e because we just
flipped the edge, but we
can get a pebble from d,
so we flip that edge.
And now we can add the
edge af to more edges.
It's a little tedious.
So next is cf.
We're running out
of pebbles here.
There's only five pebbles
total in the system.
We need four of them
right here because we're
getting almost rigid.
So let's see.
We've got cf.
Let's start from
searching from f.
There's only one way we can go.
We find a pebble.
We flip it around.
Now we've got c.
There's only one
way to go from c.
We find the pebble at e.
And we flip it around.
Now we've got the two pebbles.
Cool.
So we've got the
three pebbles here,
which are representing our
translations and rotations.
The only other pebble
left is this one,
which is basically representing
the degree of freedom
in this quadrilateral.
So when we go to add the
last edge, which is-- so
at this point, this is
a ridge it component
because of the triangles.
And we go to add
the last edge, we
will fail to find
enough pebbles.
Let's see.
We can find three of them.
We can grab the one from e.
Or let's see so-- it's
not going to show us.
But from e, we can grab
f, the pebble at f.
From d, we can grab
the pebble at c.
the other pebble at f.
We've got three
pebbles, but there's
no way to get to this pebble
because both of these edges
are directed down.
So you can never get from the
below part to the above part.
So it's not obvious
that this is working.
That's what the proof is for.
But at least you
see it in action.
I'll just run it very
quickly for another graph.
Let's say a big one.
This one is minimally,
generically rigid.
So it's fun to
watch for a while.
You get pebbles moving around.
In this case, you
have some longer paths
you have to follow to
get enough pebbles.
It depends a lot on the
insertion order that you use.
So in each case, you need four
pebbles, two on each side.
And if so, you
can add your edge.
Otherwise, you can't.
What I haven't described
is this color coding
which is figuring out when
you have rigid components.
Roughly speaking, to find
what your rigid component is--
if you're an edge, you want to
know what rigid component am
I in-- you basically just
search for all the vertices
that are reachable
from your edge.
Those are all in
your rigid component.
That's what we saw.
So this graph happens
to be minimally rigid,
and it detects that.
But then it can be
a little bit more
as in your rigid component.
Some of the incoming
edges-- let's see.
Draw a picture.
So here's everything
you can reach from v-w.
And say you're following
an incoming edge here
from some other vertex u.
And then suppose these
are all the things
you can reach from you.
If there are zero
pebbles out here,
then this whole thing
is a rigid component.
And you just keep doing that.
You check an incoming edge.
If there's zero pebbles
in that reachable piece,
then you merge.
And you keep doing that.
Those are all the things that
are rigidly attached to you.
So I won't prove that.
It's a little tricky to
prove, but it's fairly easy
to compute.
And you could actually do it
in the same amount of time.
As you're building
this thing up,
you can do the color
coding to figure out
which things are in the
same component, which things
are in different components.
Let's see.
So another fun fact
is this little part.
This says it's the
2k minus 3 property.
The same algorithm you could
use to check 5k minus 27,
or whatever you want, for fixed
numbers like two and three,
the same pebble
algorithm can detect
that ak minus b property.
And that's actually useful
for a lot of different things.
This is done originally
by Lee and Streinu.
Same lee, and Streinu
we'll be seeing
some of her results in a
couple of classes as well.
For example-- so this is
that-- 3D body and bar.
So actually let me
show you the kind
of scenario we're
thinking about.
So I mentioned 3D.
If we have vertices
and bars between them,
we don't know how to
characterize generic rigidity.
But a slightly different
problem, which is 3D bodies,
these are polyhedron.
And they have bars
connected between them.
This we know how to solve
in 3D and in any dimension.
And so this is a picture
of not only having--
so their bodies can
spin unlike vertices.
Vertices can't rotate.
Nothing happens when
you rotate a vertex.
Bodies have this extra
degree of freedom.
So there are two things
we're allowing here,
one is to add a hinge
between two bodies
and the other is to add
bars connecting them
from various random points.
And it's generic, so these
points will never coincide.
I think that's what makes
this different from a vertex.
Vertex bars always coincide.
Here, they all just
attach to generic points.
So it turns out you can
simulate a hinge by five bars.
They're equivalent.
So both of these can be
captured by 6K minus 6 property.
Turns out these things will
be generically rigid if
and only if you satisfy
the 6K minus 6 property
and you have exactly
6K minus 6 bars.
And this is proved by
two or three people.
I mean you need to add
two results together,
one from the '90s and
one from much older,
I think, in graph theory.
But in particular, Tae
was involved from 1984.
And it's funny.
The paper starts out with, if
you ask any structural engineer
if you have two
bodies how many bars
you have to add to rigidify
them, they will say six.
I'm like, OK, I
didn't know that.
But six is the right answer.
And that's why the
6K minus 6 basically.
And and we can use
this pebble algorithm
to solve that for
free basically.
And this is actually
implemented here
in the same kind of software.
I'll just run it quickly
because it's a lot of pebbles.
Every vertex has six pebbles.
You just keep going.
You need to cover every
edge with how many pebbles?
Before it was four,
so now it should be 7,
I believe, one more
than the six here.
So 6k minus 6.
Anyway, this graph,
while it's not obvious,
is minimally rigid
in this world.
And it corresponds exactly
to the left example.
It's hard to see because
we've replaced the hinges here
by six bars.
So that's why we got all the
six-- all the duplicated edges.
Here, you see the duplicated
are different from a rigidity
standpoint because having three
edges between the same pair
of objects is no longer just
the same as having one edge
because they attach
to different points.
Each one can spin.
These are universal
joints by the way.
So these bars can
rotate around the body.
The body can spin.
Lots of things can happen.
But this is enough to rigidify.
Is there a question?
Cool.
I'm not going to prove that.
You can read the papers
if you're interested.
But it's interesting.
Bodies and bars are so much
easier than other things.
One other thing you can do
is called angular rigidity.
This is a fairly new
result by same people.
If you have a bunch of
lines in 3D, and you
have angular constraints.
In this case, every
triple of these lines
has an angular constraint that
it must be equal to alpha.
That's what's drawn on
this spherical picture.
Over here, we have two bodies.
So here we have lines.
Here, we have bodies.
And there are three
constraints that
fix the angles between how the
angles meet at these bodies.
And they claim is that both
of these are angularly rigid,
meaning things can
still slide up and down,
but the angles are all fixed.
And you can test this again.
This case actually turns out
it's the 2k minus 3 property
again, same as Laman.
This one, I've forgotten.
I have to check.
I think it's 3k minus 3.
Yeah, 3k minus 3.
So cool things.
One last question.
Connected banana.
So there's this three banana
example-- or two banana
example.
I'm getting ahead of
myself-- which was weird.
You have this one banana on the
left, one banana on the right.
And there's this implicit,
implied hinge, as they call it,
between the two points.
The whole thing is flexible,
but if you check it,
it satisfies the Lama condition.
It satisfies 3k
minus 6, which is
what it should be
for 3D rigidity.
This is a 3D.
Now, this graph is--
seems trivial-- I
mean it seems easy to figure
out that this is flexible
because there's a two cut.
There are two vertices
you can remove
that disconnect the
graph into two pieces.
So if you could just subdivide,
do the left part separately
from the right part, you should
be able to figure this out.
Unfortunately, this example
can be made more connected,
and that's what
the question was.
So this is an old
example by Henry Crapo.
A modification by
Walter Whiteley
is that if you add a single
point here and attach it
to those two points--
sorry, those three points--
this will be three connected,
still be flexible, and still
satisfy Laman because we added
three edges and one vertex,
so it still satisfies Laman.
So that sucks.
We think, oh, maybe
four connected.
Well, you can make it
four connected, too,
by adding a triangle
in the center
and connecting these six,
adding these 6 connections.
Well, what about 5 connected?
Well, five connected,
you can also do.
And this is an example
called the banana spider.
Although it seems a
bit of a misnomer.
It should be-- but I
guess banana spiders
are actual object--
actual species.
This really should
be a banana insect
because this guy
has six legs, three
on the left, three on the right.
So if it is an
octahedron in the center,
and then you add these
three connections,
and you can actually prove
that any graph you have,
any example that's maybe only
one or two or three connected,
whatever, you can make it five
connected by whenever you have
two four connected components--
or five things components
I guess-- just add a spider
in the middle to bridge them,
and it will be as
flexible as before.
And it will still satisfy Laman.
So five connectivity doesn't
buy you anything unfortunately.
I guess you could ask
for six connectivity,
but six connectivity,
I think, is impossible
because you only have
3n minus 6 edges.
That's the limit.
So sadly, connectivity is not
the right-- doesn't buy us
anything.
And that's what we know about
vertex and bar structures in 3D
sadly.
Tough open problem.
Any questions?
That's it for today.